we lost radio contact with HQ our last
order was to set up an observation post
in the village new soldier get to it
ready for duty a permanent orders
Eddie orders
what the hostiles
yes
yes Jesus Christ the whole German army
is marching here I need to get back and
report to Sarge
where they following you not a chance
sir I move like a ghost lucky they
didn't follow you home position orders
any orders infantry reporting orders
target in sight
infantry moving fire bull's eye
infantry reporting target destroyed
lawyers a target
good job soldiers they're running like
what's that noise infantry moving
infantry movie movie weary dancers
incoming let's stick to the dense forest
infantry movie infantry moving
infantryman moving infantry on the move
infantry on the move
mg moving
you
damnit where is everyone get your lazy
asses on the OT goes and get prepared
dancers are on to us
infantry mg ready coordinates 80 soldier
reporting AG soldier reporting yes
infantry infantry reporting ready for
duty actual command got it
target in sight transport ready all the
way awaiting orders and orders ready sir
transport ready
Eddie orders
fire to target find the guy hiding
diseases
I took amass yes sir
any orders on the way the dust got it
moving where you need me
artillery ready awaiting orders
ready sir
gun ready
any orders transport ready transport
ready yes sir
transport ready
ready for duty
ready for duty infants remove your units
back to the main force immediately you
don't want to stand in the way of what's
incoming yes sir
any orders yes sir
orders at your command on the way slow
be moving where you need awaiting orders
infantry reporting orders infantry
reporting infantry reporting 20 sir and
the orders to transport ready and the
orders anti-tank soldier ready yes
infantry moving yes sir yes yes orders
at your command orders ready sir
ready sir
ready for duty hurry up at your command
start engine ready for duty infantry
ready sir yes yes awaiting orders need
ammo fuel or repair any orders awaiting
orders on the way
affirmative
artillery ready mg moving got it
oMG ready at your command yes we don't
have much time till they arrive prepare
the defenses lay some anti-tank mines
we need to repel them come on
you were given additional air support
infantry reporting yes
Heikki movie
any orders done ready awaiting orders
awaiting orders yes
yes sir
moving sir awaiting orders
I took her man awaiting orders
medic reporting anti-tank sold your
ready
orders yes orders ready sir yes sir
moving sir at your command gun ready yes
come on ready sir
infantry on the moon infantry on the
move
ready sir yes at your command
ready sir anti-tank soldier ready
come on
infantry reporting ready sir
hostiles spotted on the way infantry on
the move
vehicle is operational vehicle is
operational
I took a man
I took a man infantry ready sir
yes sir
all these operational quarters fire at
the target target in sight
anti-tank soldier ready [ __ ] moving
hillary higher ready sir
ready to attack
yes sir
order
transport ready design I'd supply truck
ready awaiting orders
fire medic reporting ready sir
infantry moving yes at your command I
took her man
ready for duty ready sir
silver bow fire genetic recording yes
fire at the target
got my bandages ready
yes open fire opening fire target
destroyed
orders
at your command orders infantry moving
supply truck ready need ammo fuel or
repair yes
truck reporting that's your command
come on ready sir
awaiting orders orders yes sir the
wheels are hit awaiting orders anyone
injured excellent war incoming on both
sides we have to hold the line at all
costs I choke a man I took command yes
gun ready awaiting orders
yes more air support is available use it
well yes
infantry reporting supply truck ready
we're all way
yes sir infantry on the move
yes sir go Babu coordinates yes sir
ready to attack
yes sir
on the way
orders yes sir
supply truck ready the tracks got hit
yes
moving hurry up yes sir I took a man on
the way need ammo fuel or repair the
wheels are hit the wheels are hit we're
ready sir
any orders awaiting orders
we're always orders
I took command
reinforcements have arrived gun ready
gun ready relocating the gun enemy
sighted
hurry up ready to attack yes sir
moving sir yes yes got it on the way
resupply destination acknowledged
supply truck already
affirmative
yes come on
got it
gun ready move it ready to attack why is
the destination
the white truck ready a permanent yes a
permanent relocating the gun plus
reporters come on longer
any orders opening fire another one like
to stop any sir
supply truck ready we're rolling
mg ready yes sir target coordinates
awaiting orders yes sir ready sir
vehicle is operational
come on yes enemy
yes sir fire the target attracts cottage
we're ammo boys ready sir need ammo fuel
or repair start engines
come on transport ready ready sir
infantry on
gun ready come on
moving the gun target in sight
your net supply truck ready go
yes
some white truck ready start engines
borders
awaiting orders shovel attack
supply truck ready on the way
yes sir Anamika she demo Laura's hair
rolls I need ammo you go repair gobo yes
sir yes
firing
open fire
waiting orders enemy destroyed need ammo
fuel or repair got it
yes orders
orders all the way
a fire
I took him out
what are the coordinates
you did it they are turning back
that was a heroic defense we have to
strike now before they join their
reserve forces launched a counter-attack
and destroy them
the sky cleared up completely more air
support is available use it well
need medical assistance
affirmative enemy any orders hurry up
I choke a man
affirmative
80 soldier reporting
you
moving sir
you
you
yes yes sir yes affirmative anti-tank
soldier ready anti-tank soldier ready
enemy
at your command
loading sir
yes
that's your command
Eddie orders
moving sir yes sir yes sir
destroy yes sir
yes sir at your command outstanding job
you made history today